my mom like we lived in New Hampshire
you know like my mother would we would
go to
Dunkin Donuts and she'd be like I'd like
a croissant and the girl would be like
what I'm like Mom you're humiliating me
oh but she doesn't she'd also say
so where did that come from where did
that come from with her she wanted to
show that she was kind of fancy and
erudite what was it yeah I mean she knew
she spoke French
she went to you know she went to
a high school like Saint Mark St
Margaret's you know she went to like a
Catholic school or something or some
sort of Christian School and learned
French but she also I remember when I
was with Jimmy Kimmel
um
she was he was specific because there's
so many late night hosts named Jimmy I
know that time I was with Jimmy which
one no it was Kimmel
um but he she my mom had come to visit
and he was he was having a you know he
would have like the Christmas Eve Seven
Fishes thing yeah and then we're hanging
out and they're singing everyone's
singing Christmas carols and they're
singing Jingle Bells and my mom you know
she's passed away so now of course like
I love every piece of her but she drove
me totally insane and
she just was driving me crazy and I like
whispered to him like oh she's such a
know-it-all and just as I said
that the song ended and she goes I can
sing it in French
the most incredible timing
you called it she didn't disappoint
that's like a sitcom where they say well
as long as no idiotic blowhard gets
involved we should be fine bang Ted
Knight comes through the door of Miracle
Amor hello yes hello but that's a
perfect that was perfect oh my God I do
know there are people who
I know who's who are always insisting
that the real pronunciation is something
that it possibly couldn't be I mean it
just couldn't be so you'll say like
let's go get a gelato and they'll be
like well you know it's uh it's gelato
I'd be like what no it's gelato actually
you know this is the kind of thing
Jordan schlinsky would do who works for
us he'd he'd say and actually it I'm
sorry it comes from the German
derivation of the Italian so it's gelato
you're like no it's not at a certain
point we all agree that it's not well
that's the thing is like a certain point
like it's just made more popular the
wrong way and that makes it the right
way like my mom insisted that
to sit like say something as your Forte
it's fort
and and I believe her but no one in the
world says it that way so if you say
well that's my fort they'll go what is
you mean they built a fort no it's the
correct way of saying what all you know
as Forte
my wife says tomato and
um it didn't it in it's her family they
this is they just all say tomato and I
know that that's an old of course you
say tomato I say tomato but it's not
tomato it's just not it's not anymore
who said tomato and I was just like oh
who said who said it a woman that I know
who yeah who works with me for a short
time
it sounds negative I hired her for a she
was a decorator okay it was a short-term
contract
you let her go because she was saying
tomato but it was funny because she said
no no she she said tomato and it proved
in my mind my point which is that all uh
interior designers are come from money
because who who's a struggling interior
nobody works their way up you know like
there is no coming from nothing interior
you could put that crate over by that
Barrel
and it might create a flow
and then lay that pipe over there and
then you're right they don't start out
in an alley just arranging trash cans I
think these people are from old money
that become this and then she goes I
like the tomato color and I go I'll look
over at Rory when I tell you but it
could also be that is a Boston like my
Nana said like
you know had a Boston accent but she
said like she had a weird uh
like hot I don't know why I say like but
challah bread she'd say like Holly you
know any bread yeah like she had that
kind of like Scrappy Boston accent but
then she said boss
but it wasn't like a rich person way it
was like a Boston boss
like instead of bath yeah I'm gonna take
a bath yeah that's kind of thought I was
saying like she had a lisp and she was
saying boss or something no no but she
it's like Mid-Atlantic my mother I swear
to God the only reason I'm in comedy is
my mother always reminded me and I love
my mom uh and she's the best but she
always reminded me of Margaret Dumont
from the uh Marx Brothers movies oh the
lady who's like
oh well I please Groucho um and it was
uh
she always had a little bit of that now
let's just all settle down here now I'd
like to think we're the kind of family
that knows how to respect itself and use
the correct language and of course that
made me want to go you know and then
behave like a complete idiot
and um they took us once to a fancy
restaurant and they put down the little
bowls that you're supposed to wash your
hands in
we never went to fancy restaurants but
there was some occasion it might have
been my parents anniversary and they
took us someplace downtown Boston it was
kind of old-fashioned and they gave us a
little and we all knew it was to dip
your
hands in to clean them I'll never forget
I took my napkin I'm like 12 and I tuck
it like right into my shirt and I take a
my spoon and I go ah soups on and I
start
searching it and my mother was like
that's what washing your hands I'm like
you know
why but if she had been not doing that
she was such a good straight person that
I had to do it I had to I always say
babies
I'm sorry there was more to that oh oh
no I don't think there was you just said
so hoping that more words would come to
your sometimes I do that it was me
throwing it to you in every professional
way yeah that was like a behind the
behind the back pass by you know Magic
Johnson you know that was just like a
really cool thing I just did I just went
so and I looked at you and you're you're
supposed to like grab it yeah take the
rock to the hole and just you know wow
wow you really know basketball pretty
good Sportster over here Sportster I was
gonna say something but now I want to
say this that my dream has always been
and now I think they don't play the the
um what's the big American basketball
team they play the Washington generals
oh uh the Harlem Globetrotters yeah so I
love that Ireland Globetrotters but then
as an adult I thought wouldn't it be
great if I would go if I went to Harlem
Globetrotters games in like head to toe
Washington generals fan gear and like
the foil for the kids in the crowd you
know like this is this is their year
that you know like right right crazy
that's funny but and I looked into it
and uh they don't they like downsize so
they don't play the Washington generals
anymore they just play like whatever
local or something was the Washington
General's job to lose yeah they were
employed to lose every game and there
must have been a time when they were
just like I know this is gonna we're
gonna get in big trouble but
let's beat the Harlem Globetrotters
that'd be amazing yeah because they
could there are moments where I mean I'm
sure the Harlem Globetrotters are very
good but there are moments where they're
busy filling a bucket with confetti
um or or stewing the refs whistle when
you can you know pull off some major
plays and get ahead build a good
comfortable lead but that's not the
well it should be the point no it's okay
kids need to learn kids kids need to
learn that anyone can lose if they're
busy stuffing a a pail with confetti
yeah or like throwing a fake basketball
that comes back on a string yeah because
it has a rubber band on it kids need to
know that those kind of shenanigans can
lead to trouble I don't know it's like
wrestling right you always have to
choose someone who loses in wrestling
otherwise what's the yeah what are they
called not the foil but the uh the loser
the heel the heel the heel oh yeah the
heel or stonus term works also the loser
you know what you should when you run
out of comics to do this show you never
will but never there's too many but uh
there are some really interesting
professional wrestlers you know like
friends and it's it's kind of adjacent
like but also we don't just talk to uh
comedians
um we we talked to I think primarily
comedians kings and queens and Comedians
and down on their down on their left
royalty like really royalty from very
small countries like you got Harry and
Megan oh no oh God no no no no no this
is from the duchy of lithobanya